okay we should talk a little bit about
the health of the President of the
United States of America
there have been question marks around
Donald Trump's physical health for a
long time and this isn't Hillary has
Parkinson's sort of conspiracy stuff
this is but really a very sort of sober
and concerning issue if you think back
to the first strange statement that we
got from a medical professional about
Donald Trump's health it was that letter
from his doctor Bornstein during the
campaign which said that Donald Trump
was not only in great health he would be
the healthiest of any president in the
history of the United States which is a
really strange thing for a medical
professional to say particularly when
they've not examined former presidents
of the United States so that was weird
to begin with as a general sort of
reality it's very clear that Donald
Trump is obviously not as healthy as
President Barack Obama we only have to
go back one president and there's really
no way in which an obese 72 year-old who
eats tons of fast food and never
exercises could be healthier then the
40-something person that Barack Obama
was when he became president of the
United States as an active and in shape
person so it didn't make sense from the
get-go and we eventually found out that
dr. Bornstein actually wrote that letter
under pressure from Donald Trump Donald
Trump according to some sources actually
dictating the letter and Bornstein
ultimately acquiescing and signing off
on it so that was sort of episode one in
the Trump health situation we later
heard from dr. Ronnie Jackson who gave
from a physical and mental exam a
cognitive test the the Montreal
cognitive assessment and he came out of
it saying Trump is just in great shape
he weighs 239 pounds and is 6 foot 3
inches tall obviously untrue every
picture of Donald Trump next to people
who we know are 6-3 or even 6:1 shows
that Trump is shorter we have pictures
of Donald Trump standing next to Barack
Obama for example who is known to be 6
foot 1 and Trump looks maybe the same
height or may
be even shorter than Barack Obama so we
know Trump's not 63 and 239 in terms of
a weight just happened to be the limit
before obesity for someone who is
actually 6-3 so it didn't make any sense
it wasn't at all believable with dr.
Ronnie Jackson said and then dr. Ronnie
Jackson was nominated to be Secretary of
Veterans Affairs a nomination that
ultimately imploded and ended up with
dr. Ronnie Jackson withdrawing from that
so it all stinks that gets us up to
yesterday we now have a comment from
former Vice President Dick Cheney's
cardiologists Jonathan Reiner who says
that he believes the White House is
hiding something about Donald Trump's
latest physical exam tweeting yesterday
quote it's been four days since the
president underwent his annual physical
exam and still no data has been released
what are they hiding and indeed it has
been four days and instead of actual
information about Donald Trump's
physical exam we have this very strange
vague memo the new presidential doctor
Shawn Connelly put out a memo that's
just ridiculous at its face we have it
up on the screen Shawn Connelly wrote
this afternoon at Walter Reed National
Military Medical Center the president
participated in a second periodic
physical examination over the course of
approximately four hours I performed and
supervised the evaluation with a panel
of 11 different board-certified
specialists he did not undergo any
procedures requiring sedation or
anesthesia the president is very
grateful as if this matters for the
outstanding care he received today and
he especially wants to thank all the
doctors nurses and listed in civilian
staff who participated of course none of
this says anything about Trump's health
and then it ends with while the reports
and recommendations are being finalized
I'm happy to announce the President of
the United States is in very good health
and I anticipate he will remain so for
the duration of his presidency and
beyond how can any doctor predict in
such a casual way that a person who is
the approaching their mid-70s and obese
doesn't exercise and has a terrible diet
how can you predict that they're going
to remain in good health for the rest of
their presidency and beyond it's a very
strange assertion for a medical
professional to make it's becoming more
Pat like the North Korean propaganda of
the dear leader doesn't defecate
engulfed all holes in one the first time
he played golf it's starting to be that
type of sort of hagiographic propaganda
yeah and for me I don't think the
president has to be an impeccable shape
although that is a bonus
I think if everything gets too bad and
you know someone can always replace him
or her right but the lying is what's
concerning and not just the fact that
Trump's lying but that he has the
network of physicians who are willing to
go along with it let me give you a
counter example just so you can see what
other medical reports look like for
Presidents here's Barack Obama's report
from 2016 and you will notice that there
are very specific vital statistics about
his age height and weight his BMI his
pulse oximetry physical examination by
systems outlines eyes neck all sorts of
specifics and the second page of this
assessment actually has specific
laboratory results his lipid panel
including cholesterol numbers his
fasting blood glucose this is a serious
report about a president's weight what
medications are they on what vitamins
are they taking this isn't crazy stuff
and we don't even know what Trump's
weight is being asserted to be even
though we know the last time we were
told it was 239 it was an obvious lie I
wonder is Donald Trump on medications at
this point we don't even know the answer
to that so the point is doctors are now
noticing this even from the way that
Donald Trump just speaks incoherently at
public events it should convey to any
reasonable person that he's not in the
best of health and from what I recall
Pat tell me if I'm wrong we still
haven't gotten an explanation about the
weird god bless the United States of
America incident have we because
at one point asserted that maybe Dexter
debt dentures were related but then we
were told the president doesn't even
wear dentures what did they say it was
dry mouth something like that
when I get dry mouth I don't start
slurring my words like that I think it
was dentures for sure
well yeah again there's a denial that
the guy even wears dentures so I don't
know that we've gotten a clear answer
about that so medical professionals are
noticing and this is not about this is a
totally separate issue from Trump's
positions on issues and his ability to
negotiate deals or what I think of his
tax plan to some degree the public does
have a right to know the truth about the
president's health it's not crazy to
consider the individual's health in
making an evaluation about whether to
vote for them initially or to vote for
them for re-election and what it does
relate to is the pattern of lying and
deception and just putting out
information that most reasonable people
recognize as having holes in it or
potentially even of being downright
deceptively deliberately deceptive and
we're not getting those answers here and
we're just getting of strange comments
after strange comments from every single
medical professional who's allowed
around Donald Trump and this can't I
don't even have time to get into this
today but the Montreal cognitive
assessment that Trump was given by dr.
Ronnie Jackson meant to be proof that
Donald Trump cognitively is fine we've
learned so much about why the specifics
of those results also don't really tell
us what we need to know about Trump will
we ever know the truth I don't know but
maybe someday I am taking questions
today your questions on the David Pakman
show Instagram page if you find David
Pakman show on Instagram and go to
today's stories feed you will see that
there is a place you can type in
questions for me and I'll be answering
them throughout the afternoon and
evening for the rest of the day and
while you're there follow me on
Instagram as well
at David Pakman quick break then bill
scher will join me I've not been playing
electability games with the 20
20 Democratic primary he believes that
playing electability games at this early
stage is already very very important
we'll hear from him next